excuse me other things in life that
confuse you yes have you been cause pain
in your life from people and/or things
that are out of your control
yes are you constantly seeking various
forms of happiness to define your
purpose and or enrich the unknown amount
of time that you have to experience this
beautiful storm called life yes same my
instinct is to hurt you because I have
in the past
unwanted leap and caused pain by others
and I would like for someone else to
experience the pain that I have unjustly
felt but in thinking it through I
realized that it is not beneficial for
me to further the pattern of unwarranted
painting seeing as we are both human
beings and both merely trying to
experience whatever happiness this
historical life has to offer very cool
so instead good day and good luck in
your pursuit of happiness I'm leaving
now excu take them out but nervous has
one human to another human that seemed
like a fairly easy choice for you to
make it was I don't know